-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, it was a big day
here in New York,
as Andrew Cuomo announced that
he is resigning as governor.
During his remarks, he said it
was best that he step aside.
And then every woman in the room
took two steps aside.
During his announcement,
Cuomo said that
he's stepping down in 14 days.
I'm sorry, but is this really a
two-week-notice
type of situation?
It's gonna be tough for Cuomo.
With a track record like this,
his only future is either
president or
Supreme Court justice.
So, you know...
[ Laughter ]
Cuomo's replacement will be
Lieutenant Governor
Kathy Hochul.
And this is -- Yeah.
[ Crowd cheering ]
This is strange.
Right after she was announced as
New York's next governor,
CNN offered a prime-time show
to her sister.
-Really?
-Yeah.
What a day.
The news definitely
can't get any worse
for powerful guys named Andrew.
-Prince Andrew
facing a new lawsuit filed by
Jeffrey Epstein accuser
Virginia Roberts Giuffre.
-Okay, maybe it can get worse.
Today, the queen called
Harry and Meghan and was like,
"Can I crash with you
for a while?"
It's been such a tough year,
the queen now answers
the phone like,
"Oh, good Lord, what now?"
When his lawyer said he'll never
get another job again,
Prince Andrew was like,
"Another what?
Job?"
How about we shift gears
to some positive news, huh?
Today, the Senate passed
President Biden's
$1.2 trillion infrastructure
bill with bipartisan support.
That's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's good news.
That's positive.
That's right --
a trillion dollars to fix
our roads, bridges,
and airports.
So after they finish LaGuardia,
that will leave us
with about 40 bucks.
It's amazing we can pass a
$1 trillion infrastructure bill,
yet we can't find the new host
for "Jeopardy!"
Speaking of crazy things,
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
is threatening to withhold pay
from any school officials
who require masks.
I'm nervous about DeSantis.
I mean, right now people in
Florida are like,
"When can Cuomo start?"
You know what I'm saying?
That's not good, you know?
As employers around the country
urge their workers
to get vaccinated,
the owner of an eyewear store
ran into a strange concern
from one employee.
Watch this.
-An optical-business owner
says he can't convince
all of his employees
to be vaccinated.
One employee said she was
concerned because she thought
a vaccine had caused
the characters in the film
"I Am Legend"
to turn into zombies.
[ Laughter ]
-So I'm guessing the
requirements to get a job
at that store
are not that demanding.
Seriously, vaccine or not,
you might want to
stop that woman
from coming into the office.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
Last night was the final episode
of "The Bachelorette."
We love that show. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And one of the
big moments from the episode
was when the final contestant,
Blake, met Katie's Aunt Lindsey.
Take a look at how their
conversation went.
-So, what made you
want to go on this season
after you flunked
out of the last one?
-Yeah, flunked.
[ Both laugh ]
Yeah, I've been dumped twice.
There was two Bachelorettes
that showed up.
One left --
-And neither of them wanted you?
-I guess not.
-Like,
you ultimately mean nothing.
Like, hate to break it to you,
but, like,
you better be secure as [bleep]
coming into our family,
because at the end of the day,
you're here because
we want you here,
not because we need you here.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-It's nice when someone welcomes
you into the family
by quoting Joe Pesci
in "Goodfellas."
That's right -- the season
finale of "The Bachelorette"
was last night, and Katie and
Blake are officially engaged.
You know that show
can get pretty emotional,
so I thought we could help.
Here's a clip from
the episode re-voiced
with the least-emotional person
we know, Siri.
This is "Let's Get Siri-ous."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Whispering ]
"Let's Get Siri-ous."
-[ Robotic voice ]
My entire day and evening
with Blake was truly perfect.
Yum. Yum.
And the fact that we could
open up the way we did
during the dinner, it really
changed our relationship.
Last night was, I think,
everything I could have
hoped for.
Me, too.
Mwah.
Mwah. Mwah.
Mwah. I love you.
Mwah.
Love you, too.
Mwah. Bye. Bye.
Mwah, mwah, mwah.
Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Mwah, mwah, mwah."
That's right -- as I said,
it was a three-hour finale
of "The Bachelorette,"
and a lot of people
are talking about the
"After the Final Rose" special,
when Katie -- You know what
I'm talking about?
Katie confronted her ex, Greg.
Yeah, but you don't have to
take my word for it,
because here to
re-enact this moment
with actual lines from the show
are Tariq and Questlove.
Guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks, Jimmy.
Tonight, I'll be playing Katie,
who is finally about to accuse
her ex, Greg,
of lying about his intentions.
-And I'll be playing Greg,
who is about to experience
Katie's full wrath.
-Great. Well, whenever
you guys are ready.
♪♪
-You're saying I'm not
"validating" you enough,
but it's like,
you got a First Impression Rose.
You got a first one-on-one.
The second one-on-one,
every single group date.
Oh, man, I feel like
you were never ready
for an engagement.
-I'm honestly so confused
as to why you would think that.
Um, I wouldn't -- Wow!
-You didn't even
bother to say goodbye.
You say you love me,
but I don't think
you know what love is,
because that
was a time I needed...
I needed you the most...
and you ran away.
-Well, I understand that you
found what you're looking for.
-Oh, absolutely!
I am very happy.
Oh, but -- but
that doesn't take away from
the anger
and the way you treated me --
using me to get
the experience, the exposure,
dare I say, the acting practice
at my expense!
-[ Chuckles ]
The acting?
-I mean, it was pretty good.
Until the end, when you kind of
F'd it up and ran away!
-Look,
I hate to break it to you,
but as much as I wish I was,
I'm not Meryl Streep.
-Oh, we know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. Oh, my God!
That was unbelievable.
That's Questlove and Tariq,
everyone.
That was actually unbelievable.
Oh, my -- Wow. Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's very nice.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, thank you.
Good to see you.
Questlove and Tariq, everybody.
Yeah, there you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, get this.
I read that Disney
just released the prices
for its new "Star Wars"
Galactic Starcruiser hotel,
and it can cost you up to $6,000
for a two-night stay.
While over at the Marriott,
6 grand will get you
the entire Marriott.
Yeah, 6 grand.
Even worse, when you ask for
the "Star Wars" honeymoon suite,
they say it's booked by
a brother and a sister.
[ Audience groans ]
-Come on!
-That's...
-Come on. Luke and Leia.
-Well, finally, I saw that
Pepsi and Boston Beer
are teaming up to create
an alcoholic Mountain Dew drink
called Hard Mountain Dew.
Here's a photo.
Yeah.
Meth is actually
a gateway drug to that.
What's crazy is that half
of America refuses the vaccine
but will have no problem
putting that into their body.
Can we see the cans again?
They look like what a kid
draws to show his parents
what his nightmares are about.
Hard Mountain Dew
is actually a lot healthier,
because the
alcohol helps kill whatever
is in normal Mountain Dew.